[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
I'm here at Marvel Studios with
the head of visual development,
Ryan Meinerding.
Hello, sir.
Hello.
I wish we could
go to your office,
but apparently it's
full of spoilers?
There's a lot of stuff on the
walls that people can't see.
Well, I have an NDA,
so I'm going to find out
all the secrets after
this interview when
the cameras aren't rolling.
But for now, let's
talk about Mysterio.
When me and the rest of
the fans saw the trailer,
we were like holy smokes, that
is one big, swashbuckling,
heroic looking Mysterio.
And he has a pretty
kind of fun campy
origin story in the comics.
So how do you start
to play with that
in turning it into that look?
With his look from the comics,
because it's essentially--
in some version, it's
more like a green onesie.
LORRAINE CINK: Yeah.
RYAN MEINERDING: The
idea of it being more
of a classic superhero suit
meant we were looking at things
we've done for Vision--
just saying, OK, how
could we translate
that into something that
was reasonable for Mysterio?
See, now that you've said
it's a onesie, all I can wonder
is if it has little
buttons in the back.
[LAUGHING]
RYAN MEINERDING: It doesn't.
It has a zipper
somewhere, but no--
no buttons.
It's Mysterio-ous, though.
Yeah, very nice.
[LAUGHING]
One of the things we do
just to automatically make
something feel more
real in some ways
is just to make it metallic.
[LAUGHING]
I mean, the second you use a
metallic paint on his suit,
it just feels more real.
It gives life to the--
when he's moving around, there's
reflections playing off of it,
and it just doesn't
feel dead or flat.
He's got such
a long comic book
history from way back in 1964.
Where did you start with
those original Ditko drawings
and bring it into today?
I mean, I always love looking
back at the old artwork.
The older it is, the better,
because it usually starts
from such a unique place.
And that's one of the reasons
why MCU characters tend to end
up looking sort of more unique.
With the Ditko stuff, I
mean, he drew hands so well,
and he also--
the weirdness of the
characters really came through,
whether it was in Spider-Man or
Mysterio or in Doctor Strange--
and then also just, the main
icon being that fishbowl.
Like, how can we
get that in there
and-- and have it
not look goofy?
LORRAINE CINK: Well, and
that's an interesting question,
too, because one of
the things I always
think about-- that fishbowl look
in the comics-- it's so cool.
But you're like, how does
he get his head in there--
Right.
--if it is a
perfectly round sphere?
So how do you solve for that?
So we were actually
trying to do that.
We were seeing if
early on it would
be better if we
turned it into more
of an actual
head-friendly shape.
And then you do it, and it just
doesn't look like Mysterio.
And that's one of the things
that, when you start down
these roads of-- of
looking at what was done
in the past from the comics
and seeing how to translate it
for a screen, there's
so many problems
that are solved for
us that we don't
necessarily even register.
So I tried to do other versions
of the big fishbowl head
without the cloak
or a smaller cloak,
and it just doesn't work.
Ditko got it right
the first time.
There's so many fun little
details from the comics that
always appear in the films.
I'm a huge comic
book reader and fan,
I know our fans are as well.
Do you have maybe three
little Easter eggs for us
that you can tell us from
the original visual design?
For Mysterio, specifically?
Mm-hmm.
I mean, I think working
in eyes as many places
as we could--
I think we got them
here on the clasps.
They're in his-- when
he uses his powers,
there's sort of a triangle
with an eye in it.
There's other very
subtle things that I
don't know if you would really
want to see them if you--
But w--
[LAUGHING]
I want to know.
If you look at
something like--
classic superhero
costumes usually
have some version of a letter--
a symbol or a letter on it.
Yeah.
Mysterio doesn't in
the comics, typically,
other than the eye clasps--
sort of did that to Mysterio.
There's a bunch of vertical
bands around his stomach
that are essentially
Ms that are repeating.
LORRAINE CINK: I love that.
RYAN MEINERDING:
It's very subtle,
and once you see it you
can't unsee it, so beware.
[LAUGHING]
OK.
Also, I want to say that
you took a bold move
and you gave Mysterio a beard.
What's-- what's up
with bearded Mysterio--
RYAN MEINERDING:
Bearded Mysterio.
LORRAINE CINK:
--besides the fact
that Jake Gyllenhaal
looks great with a beard?
I think a lot of it has
to do with Jake Gyllenhaal
looking great with a beard.
OK.
I mean, in a lot
of ways, this movie
is Peter trying to come to
terms with being his own hero
and not living
under Tony's shadow.
And I think having
another mentor
that also had a goatee also is
a symbol of age, in some ways--
being seasoned in the world.
And I-- and more directly
relating it to Tony,
I think that connection
is great to have visually.
I got to view some
of your iterations
of the Mysterio entire design.
How many iterations do you
think you went through?
RYAN MEINERDING:
Probably-- he's one
of those characters
who can go in a lot
of different directions.
Any of the characters
that really have
a very unique and
interesting origin visual
means that when you translate
it to in a story world
that needs to be more
realistic, it needs to be
grounded in something else.
So we've-- I don't know.
I probably tried between
60 and 70, I think.
It took about that many
to get through, um,
for the producers and Jon
to really feel like it--
it was working.
One of the best
parts of this job
is really being able to work
with amazing filmmakers and--
and turn their
ideas into something
that's real based on the comic
origins of the characters.
Marvel Studios is
unique in, you know,
really how much we're
able to try and translate
from the comics,
and how truthful we
try to be true to the
uniqueness and the greatness
of those icons.
And working with the
filmmakers to do that is--
is a real treat.
And you've been here since
the very beginning of Marvel
Studios, is that right?
Yeah, I was fortunate
enough to get hired
by Jon Favreau on Iron Man 1.
So it was-- design
the Mark I Iron Man
suit, which was a lot of fun.
I'm just, like, sitting
here with a little piece
of Marvel history.
That's you.
Oh.
That's very kind.
[LAUGHING]
Thank you so much
for talking with us.
Oh, thank you for having me.
It's been great.
And you guys, be sure to
go see Spider-Man: Far From
Home in theaters on July 2.
[MUSIC PLAYING]